eux ce sont les moines shaolin les
fondateurs du mont joux se couchent
chinois millénaire et ils fascinent les
occidentaux depuis les années 70 thank
you very much et nous savons que les
exercices étaient très difficiles
because de sable à cette époque des
acteurs comme david carradine oumou sy
les ont depuis l'arrivée à la télé et au
cinéma on sait vous que bruce lee y aura
des successeurs je ne pense pas on
essaye un content d'avoir des
successeurs de bruce lee medetic doués
comme lui j'en ai encore jamais vu pour
égaler broussy une seule solution
prendre des cours
en france la première association
française de shaolin voit le jour à la
toute fin des années 60 et ce
journaliste présente le kung fu
comme un sport facile à pratiquer pour
les occidentaux cette forme d'art
martial devrait se répondre facilement
car elle s'adapte parfaitement à la
morphologie des européens qui n'ont pas
la souplesse des asiatiques pour les
techniques de gens et tout le monde peut
pratiquer le karaté shaolin hommes
femmes et enfants dans les années 90
toujours le même engouement est toujours
les mêmes clichés tous asséné en chine
en tout cas du côté de shaolin si je me
rappelle bien ce que j'ai vu dans kung
fu la télé avec des vides car l'insee
très bien ses citoyens go de mémoire
avec les années 2000 fini les références
aux films d'action
désormais les apprentis shaolin sont
davantage sensibilisés aux vraies
racines de cet art martial
la quête de l'équipe passent commande
dans les films c'est beaucoup de
bagarres beaucoup de violence c'est très
très loin de l'esprit d'aujourd'hui et
ja maintenant on vous cherche lester
l'esthétisme dompter le corps l'esprit
et c'est payant puisqu'en 2012 à macao
paul rondo 16 ans est le premier
français à devenir champion du monde
juniors de kung fu wushu le droit du
patient parce que kung fu ça vient pas
d'un cours soit un long terme
en tout cas si la magie du wushu de
shaolin agit sur vous sachez que pour la
première fois aux jeux olympiques de
2020 à tokyo vous pourrez admirer les
prouesses des meilleurs champions de la
discipline
[Musique]